the stif very good day for those who
already know me I know you that
I am a language lover and a
motor of language learning
I really like learning languages
k say 15 16 and whose set that
i learned after after the age of
sixty 60 now i am
now 70 and well and then now
i am in a to what we call
at link she ing q this is our site
for learning  of languages
e a kind of what is calle
the 90 day chall
nge 90 day challenge where we want
s to learn we our learn
rs our members focus on le
rning a language and who make more
ffort  so that every day
he is there studied listening to reading
finally doing whatever it takes to
learn
me I chose local nothing it's a
language that it's not the first
time I've tackled Koreans  but I
'm making progress and every day I
tell little what I do what I  i
feel like progress finally and
all but it just so
happens that like ten days ago my wife had
to have an operation for her
global bagnasco bunions the englishman is there on
one foot and now she is a
little immobilized  so I have to do
the meals prepared the meals do the
food and I started to tell
a little about what I do and I'm going to do
that today in France is from elsewhere
since the speak French this evening I
have just received  my membership card of
the association of former students of
sciences po and I did sciences po 1
60 65 65 66 64 à 66 rue saint
guillaume in paris it was the
wonderful wonderful years and I keep
very very beautiful memories  of my stay
in france and i go there every few
years and with my wife and she
loves this country very much
good what i know what i
prepare there for
my wife first of all i was a  little busy we had
an appointment with my son that there is
let's say it  the chief operating officer
I don't know how it's said in
French de link and we had
gone to meet with a university
where we're going there maybe there will be
cooperation that we'll see so I
wanted to join a little late
I have a kind of
utilitarian spirit when it comes to
prep food it has to be good
of course but when I see what's left
in the fridge I always like to
try to use this  that there are so
I really like vegetables so yes
I saw that there were pears have
so it's called red
there
was radicchio couldn't begin
to say to each other in French there were
endives
there was fennel then me there I
cut all that I mixed that in a
kind of bowl of salad with
olive oil salt the pears and it's a
little parsley I don't know why  because we
also had to use the parsley that
we finally had a lot of fries I
put all that in the oven put that before  ec to
read it and all that to jenny some finally
time of earth that I heated in the
microwave a little there principle
put on the dish that I put in the
oven I put that in the oven for 30
minutes
by the  afterwards I also took some
batteries because there were some left in the
fridge I wanted to get rid of them
there too the enemies I put them in
the microwave just like later
on the same plan in the oven then my
wife told me to cut the mushrooms
we had which was also a bit
old then she helped me because
she took we also had to eat turkey meat from
the cheats we had bought
from  quite thin slices that
she has so is there he made the
show first heat the onions in
the pan
then from the mushrooms then
then tomatoes that I cut point g cut
is also in vain all that was necessary
do the work I do her
because she can't stand for
very long and  so I cut
everything that needed to be cut and put it in
the pan and then she made her com so
there were two places and I even
took the pictures that I'm going to show and
that's what  and we eat it and it's
with a good wine from the okanagan
the valley in the interior here in our
province of
british columbia and it's a wine
that costs $15 16 which is very good and
after that because  a few
weeks ago I had but maybe a
week I had ft adil cheeses at a
cheesemonger and thierry therefore had to match
after 12 months
a kind of French blue cheeses
saint agathe
he had told me the name j  I forgot then
another French cheese and we
fine cheeses to dry up in canada but
every every evening when we eat them we
eat to help quite thin slices
so it still lasts
a week then with lover
also tears
a stolen beauty  for us it lasts at
least two days and then I have the pump
so that it goes bad in France and in
europe
as usual and tomorrow we'll have to
do something else but here's a bit of
an explanation of what I'm doing for
another dinner but my main interest is
food too but it
's language learning and I'm going to
continue  in this series telling
how japan the korean
thank you very much